[Music]
in new zealand
this is a sheep and this is gandalf
most people come to new zealand to check
out the country's unmatched beauty
and to get their middle earth fix and
that makes perfect sense
but on this trip i'm hunting for
something else
something less obvious i'm after the
innovations being brought to life
behind these doors in these buildings
and in this studio i'm heading out on a
400 mile journey
across new zealand's north island from
auckland to wellington to find the most
breathtaking inventions these kiwis have
cooked up
you said it wasn't gonna be friday this
is the first one that's gonna go up yep
the computer model has just become
conscious of something on this episode
of hello world
we'll check out a mad scientist some
rockets
and an ai baby hi baby i will either
warm your heart
or leave you weeping over humanity's
grim future
[Music]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello world
oh hello sky phallus
[Applause]
this is auckland the home to 1.5 million
of new zealand's 4.5 million people
people living outside of auckland
tend to knock it as congested and hectic
meanwhile people living in auckland
celebrate the way of life it offers oh
here's that gelato place everybody's
trying to go to
the city has a bustling food scene
there's a gorgeous harbor surrounded by
fertile volcanic land
and those gannets and black sand beaches
you saw earlier
they're just a half hour drive from
downtown
this next part's gonna sound cheesy but
honest to god it's true
auckland is full of cheery optimistic
people
you feel good when you're here like you
can do stuff
big stuff crazy stuff
like say replicating human consciousness
on the inside of a computer
face it's our primary means of
communication
[Music]
yeah but it's been untapped in terms of
a human computer interface
how can i help you a computer can
express itself to you
in a human-like way which is emotional
it's cognitive
no no that's when you start getting to
this
sort of interesting place going to see
an ai baby
on a sunny afternoon
the fella you meet next is a madman in
the best possible way
i'm going to pull the muscles which
basically lower the brow
is mark seger a computer scientist at
the university of auckland
so nose wrinkler would be yeah let's do
your nose wrinkle adventures nose up
mark became famous for building super
detailed simulations of the human body
and ended up winning a couple of oscars
for his work on films like
avatar and king kong so let's go here
and
[Music]
these days mark is how to put this
trying to reverse engineer the human
brain he's built a series of simulations
around how the human face moves
how we express emotion and how our
neurons fire
we're trying to build a computer which
has experiences can imagine
and basically has its own sort of
existence in a way
so now what we're going to do is i'm
going to run baby x
what we're building here is a computer
that can learn
so this is baby she's sort of
looking at us and hearing us so if i
make a loud noise and i should get a
flight
this is what she can see so you can see
my face here
i see that all right so she's not
copying my smile she's responding to me
and now this is her little first baby's
first word book
so you can pick a figure page you know
show her something but she has to be
looking at it so get her attention
hi baby hi hi hi
what do you see what's this
puppy puppy fairy good what's that baby
apple this is because we're in new
zealand you've got to show your sheep
yeah
give her the word yeah yeah hi baby hi
what do you see baby sheep very good
baby
the long-term goals is can we create a
computational model of consciousness
because then you can go okay the
computer model has just become conscious
of something
is that thought or not now all the
facial expressions everything's driven
by neural nets
so as we look around what i'm going to
do is now is remove her face basically
and so this is what's driving in the
background and so what you're looking at
now
these are all the connections lighting
up right as the baby's doing stuff
and this is like a simulation of what
would you have running person's brain
yeah because if you're going to make a
character biological and behave
naturally then you've got to use a
natural model so
that's the sort of what's going on
inside baby x
now we take this stuff and we now
connect it to cognitive computing
systems
so you've got biological neural networks
connected to
artificial intelligence models and the
potential for that's enormous
that's where the future's probably going
to be maybe
[Music]
there's a term new zealanders have for
possessed inventor types like mark
they're part of the country's number
eight wire culture
like so many things here the story of
number eight wire goes back to those
sheets
farmers used to make their fences out of
eight wire gauge metal
then they started to use the wire to fix
just about any problem on the farm
over time a number eight wire mythology
evolved
to capture the can-do spirit of people
living in a remote place
and of the people who had to solve
problems in any clever way they could
but while new zealanders remain fond of
the eight-wire idea there's an
undeniable sense that the country is
ready to level up
it's time to start inventing with more
purpose and polish
the gritty garage workshop is giving way
to this
a pristine mad scientist lab that looks
like it could be for sale
in an apple store
saray avery embodies kiwi ingenuity
he's a prolific scientist and inventor
sir avery this is
ashley vance he made a fortune in the
pharmaceutical industry
and then decided to dedicate his life to
helping the world's poorest people
hence the sir all right this way it's a
cool house
right so this is the magic wardrobe i
followed sur avery through a wardrobe
door
into his garage slash lab where he
creates his objects
i know everything in the house is white
and you're wearing white yeah yeah yeah
i mean i'm a bit like steve jobs i have
two dresses i have black for winter
and white for summer but the thing is
that i know that i've got 4
days left to live how do you know that
well because i've done the algorithm
analysis of somebody my age bought at my
time how much chardonnay i drank all
that sort of [ __ ]
so i know what i'm going to do with the
next 10 years of my life failure
is really just for people are unprepared
you don't waste time
on things that aren't going to get you
to where you need to go in things like
clothes
survey is well known for taking
complicated medical devices
and making them simple cheap and durable
did you make this in here yeah yeah this
is your workshop
lab currently he's working on this
incubator
it really is a live pod because it's
almost like you know something that
superman would be happy to be in and the
shape of it
uh is really much more about getting
even air distribution and trying to make
it look cool
the life pod cost 2 000 versus forty
thousand dollars for typical incubators
the hope is that it could save thousands
of lives each year
i'll show you this is really cool and
this is oh my god
it's pretty pretty pretty ugly he also
has this giant block of frozen chicken
slurry as a way to amplify the
nutritional value
of trash meat so that's after kentucky
fried have taken all their bits the legs
and the chest meat
they make it into this stuff mmm chicken
slurry
guys have a spoonful of that later soray
remixes the trash meat with of all
things
kiwi this breaks it down into the basic
amino acids so your body can absorb the
nutrients more easily
it's aimed at helping malnourished
children if you take that then you're
going to get instant energy you don't
need to digest it go straight across
your gut
this will save millions and millions of
kids alive
you know einstein said the most elegant
solution
is always the most simplest and kiwis
have that a very practical way of doing
things
if you take away the noise that you have
often with things like silicon valley
and you just have a bunch of guys in
sheds with a lathe and a few bits and
pieces they come up with stuff that
nobody else has thought of
[Music]
i think new zealanders don't think big
enough
they don't go after the really big
problems and the big
billion dollar ideas
[Music]
i started building rockets when i was at
school
[Music]
and the very first rocket that i built i
ended up putting on a bicycle
most rocket companies are started by
wealthy governments and billionaires
rocket lab was started in 2007 by this
maniac
peter beck
peter is one of the most capable people
on the planet
he never went to college opting instead
to hone his own engineering craft in the
garage and machine shops
i don't know why rockets make me so
happy
now he wants to make it much easier and
cheaper to put small satellites
into space if you had a satellite on
your lap right now
in one week i can have that in orbit
moreover i can have that on all but in
order magnitude less cost
than any other way of getting it there
the first rocket launch will take place
later this year
wow this is the first one that's going
to go up yep
commercial customers have already signed
up and there's a two-year waiting list
how much are you going to charge per
flight we're 4.9 million dollars okay
4.9 million dollars might seem like a
lot but it's actually a remarkable
figure
and liftoff of the falcon 9 rocket and
dragon
the cheapest way to get to space today
is on one of elon musk's rockets from
spacex
and that cost 60 million dollars per
trip
rocket labs prices would open space to a
whole new set of customers
including scientists and businesses and
in effect democratize space this is what
the aerospace world has dreamed of for
decades
this is the second stage second stage
you can lift it up
you rolled your eyes a little bit at
this eight wire thing why is that
if someone says you know rocket lab is a
number eight wire company
they'll get escorted off the site
they're just gone because
number eight wire it's about sort of
bodging stuff together to make it work
and that's really not what new
zealanders have evolved to
it's about really high-tech innovation
and doing really really clever things
with launch day approaching the pressure
is on
today they're running an engine test at
a site near the auckland airport
so the worst case scenario blows up and
the best case is how does it deal with
shut down
building a company is hard yeah building
a rocket company
damn near insane i hitched a ride with
peter to the test site and arrived just
in time for
countdown three two one
the engine test was successful but
there's still a ways to go
what does it feel like in your gut with
that countdown clock
in the office and everything that comes
with sleep much
that's probably the best answer for that
question with a bit of luck
peter will maintain his sanity through
2017.
that's when rocket lab plans to start
flying for paying customers
this is a tiny company of a hundred
people that will have bested entire
nations
and firmly put new zealand's stamp on
the world
that's not eight wire culture that's
just flat out amazing
and with that it's now time to leave
auckland
and journey to middle earth
we could have flown from auckland to
wellington and it would have taken an
hour but we wanted to be basted in
hobbit vibes
we had to see the land
[Music]
dear laptop new zealand is everything
they said it would be
plus burgers smells like food tastes
like
pork rind if aliens ever visit earth
and want to see what it has to offer
their first stop would have to be new
zealand
it's like a sampler platter of
landscapes rolling hills
deserts plains tropical forest
whizzing by one after another
that's it for now thanks for listening
laptop
love ashley
[Music]
three hours outside of auckland we made
a pit stop
at a hot spring
[Music]
all the signs leading into this place
warn you that you'll get meningitis if
you stick your head under water
i'm hoping that i live after this
relaxing
afternoon
[Music]
now the more i learned about the
meningitis
the more afraid i am that i have the
meningitis
you know you come to new zealand and
it's all a wire culture
you can send up rockets next to you know
you dunk your head under water then
you're dead so less important
this mud is cool just reminds me of all
the
flipping around my brain
welcome to a rainy and famously windy
wellington
new zealand's capital city and home to a
thriving film industry
director peter jackson is the local boy
made good
he famously made lord of the rings here
and then shot past being a one-hit
wonder
peter has created an entire movie
industry based around his film
production company
weta this is wellywood
it's just like hollywood but without any
of the glitz and glamour
studio lots and sound stages are dull
and unmarked
they're tucked into a quiet suburb
called miramar
weta has started to expand into virtual
reality
and i was invited to take a look at
their first vr
movie a scene from the hobbit where smog
wakes up from a nap
you said it wasn't gonna be friday
in the shadows
that's crazy man i mean you feel like
real emotions when you see it
that's the nice thing about your art you
get people get such a much more
emotional experience than seeing
something like a video game or whatever
and i think that's kind of where the
space we're in the content generation
and the custom technology
on the software side to kind of enable
these these high-end experiences
[Music]
next the studio where they filmed lord
of the rings
i just want to grab that and have a look
around where i got a crash course in
motion capture filmmaking
using peter jackson's very own
custom-made camera
which isn't really a camera but more of
a device to place a director
in a virtual world there's a screen on
the top that shows a rough version of
the final graphics
while dozens of sensors around the room
record all of the cameras movements
all you've got to do is yell action yep
they'll do this stuff and you say cut
like any other film
action get
this tech brings a human element back to
green screen filmmaking it's more
tactile
it makes the director actually feel like
he's shooting the film again
all right cut
really good sport thanks
became an industry of its own and after
the success of lord of the rings
spawned startups that are their own mini
wettest
i'm ashley on my last stop i went to one
of these startups
eight eye studios it's a vr company that
is recording people in three dimensions
to bring them
into virtual reality
the difference from looking at a video
to seeing a hologram
that looks just like the real thing is
so powerful
adai is developing software that will
bring vr to the masses
the day you can capture a loved one in
virtual space is almost here
[Music]
we'll show you some experiences where
we've captured some humans with
off-the-shelf cameras
it feels like you're in the room with a
person can i check it out
sure all right so you can see the room
yep all right so oh
hello we create a virtual environment
but then
we capture a very lifelike motion of the
cloth and the human performance
and we can compose those together so
you'd been a weta we're used to making
these cgi
fantastic creatures but it just wouldn't
work for a normal person to have to
you don't want to drop a visual effects
hollywood production budget
just to record your child experiencing
their first steps right
and as we saw that these headsets were
coming along there was no clear
efficient
cheap scalable solution to capture
reality and to author experiences
at a scale and at a realism and at a
pace that would create a similar sort of
content database for people to enjoy
let's see how your fear of heights is so
this is going to be like a movie
oh my god that's crazy
because i'm sort of like afraid of
heights usually
[Laughter]
i mean i felt like i was gonna like walk
off a cliff that was really frightening
although i was a bit skeptical it was
time to scan myself
so i could meet the virtual ashley
[Music]
which way do i look like this way you
don't have to look anywhere okay you're
captured from
from all sides so have fun and i just
have to stay in the circle
pretty much i was surrounded by 30
cameras
all perfectly spaced and measured it was
like an
ocd paparazzi i'm ashley vance
except i'm not really ashley vance i'm a
digital asset that's being made
at 8i studios
and then in post they put together all
those different angles to make a final
3d version of me if you want to get
really nerdy this is called volumetric
cinematography
just for the nerds hands and pockets
hands and pockets it's my little virtual
friend so i get to see my virtual
selfies yes
you've seen yourself many many times in
2d video so
i think i would be underwhelmed i think
i'm just going to see what i always look
like in the mirror i don't know why
seeing like a 3d version of yourself
would be a big deal i would much rather
be chased by smog
so i can just walk around now that's
kind of strange
the detail's insane i mean you can see
like whiskers right yeah
i mean the cameras are just that good
and we're looking to increase that
resolution as well
give yourself a smooch
[Laughter]
step into yourself oh no that is crazy
whoa i also did not know where i was in
the room
so i thought it would be really janky
and i mean it is
lifelike you know and so that i guess
was the biggest surprise for me
so do you think people are gonna want vr
to be human i've got two boys
and they grow up so quick and it's like
ah man if you could just
remember how they talked and their
gestures and the funny things they said
that would be really cool
here's the thing about new zealand its
economy today depends on sheep
cows and tourists and everyone knows
that needs to change
technology is the country's future
thanks to companies like rocket lab rex
bionics and 8y
the change is already underway
foreign investors have started to pour
money into new zealand
and engineers are staying at home
because there are good jobs to be
had if you're an outsider looking to
come here well
why not the scenery is breathtaking the
weather is good
and the eight-wire days have passed new
zealand is taking on some of the hardest
problems in the industry it's working
on the technology of the absurd
[Music]
on the next episode of hello world i go
to sweden and hang out with moose
hunters at the arctic circle
that's amazing take over the country's
electrical grid seems incredible to me
that two people would handle
half a country's power and eat cinnamon
buns with spotify's daniel eck
you like him seems more wholesome than
like a cinnabon